i just got to a point where i thought
it's time to empower myself and you know
what some of this is your fault because
you've said something you'd met someone
yeah you spoke to i can't 51
that
it's been my life
and i accept it like you say acceptance
actually can be a beautiful thing and it
can be a liberating thing to think
i'm not
holding on to something that i can't
change
so first of all the conversation was
well done i didn't know about this
and then overnight the doll turned that
that definitely was
like
do you know what actually i was scared
of taking my kid to nursery that day
because i got death threats
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast thank you so much michelle humes
once upon a time she was a member of the
saturdays one of the most famous uk girl
bands that has ever risen from this
country
but since then she's become so much more
she is a mother she is a fearless
entrepreneur and honestly she is one of
the most pleasant wonderful
authentic guests i've ever had on this
podcast
and i can see why after having this
conversation with her she's built this
huge engaged community behind her online
and i think you're going to see that too
she's inspiring she is wise she is
resilient but she's also
just unbelievably real
and today we talk about something she's
never addressed before the moment where
she was nearly cancelled unanswered
questions from her childhood and also
the all-consuming side of starting and
running a business that people just
never talk about
the difficult times the rejection the
struggle with work-life balance
and in her words
how she's just winging it anyway
and i kind of think we are all just
winging it
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
just me and mama i was reading um about
the start of your life and going through
multiple interviews and that phrase kept
coming up
just me and mum
why was it just you and mum
it was just me and mum because that's
sort of how my childhood looked my mum
and
my dad split officially when i was a
tiny
probably my son's age probably maybe one
just short of one
and then
that was sort of it really so that sort
of
i had contact with my dad for a little
burst of time but it was never anything
solid
and then the contact
stopped all together so yeah that
i suppose i actually it's funny that you
point that out because i didn't realize
how much i say that but it just me and
mum is probably something that
i have said a lot you're right
i am i had a
a relative show up one day when i was
maybe 12 right and they claimed to be my
uncle they just walked into the shop and
they claimed to be my uncle and they
presented evidence which was really
compelling they were my uncle they
strolled in
and um they spoke to my dad and they
said i'm your brother and they looked at
me and said i'm your uncle and it was a
really bizarre point in my life because
although we believed them and they had
evidence to prove that they were there
was no relationship there and i i read
that you went in search of your dad to
just to find out who he was and what was
going on at some point in your life can
you tell me how that interaction was and
what you what you felt yeah i think
my mum did very well uh at
not sort of discrediting my dad over the
years so she would kind of make a lot of
excuse well now i'm an adult and i'm a
parent right i know that she was
obviously
covering his ass constantly and making a
lot of excuses and dressing it up in a
way that i suppose that at the time i
could handle as a as a kid but you're
always going to have that level of
curiosity
in life when i had my own children
i weirdly became less curious
which is weird right
because i had my own kids and i suppose
i've always thought oh yeah he's my dad
and
oh he's not been around i don't really
know him but he's my and i sort of
held hope
but then i had my own children
and i saw what being a dad was from my
husband
and i knew what being even not being a
dad was being a parent was because i was
then
a parent and besotted and in love and
lived live my life for my kids
so i think the respect
was here
but it was in the basement when i had my
own you know because
i my outlook was then like okay now i
really don't understand the way that you
don't want to be a part of your child's
life you know for some people that
changes they have their own kids and
then i'd like them to know their
grandparents or i'd like them and i
thought
my biggest thing in life is to protect
these little ones
i know how flaky you were for me
there's no way that i'd have them sat by
the window saying is granddad coming to
get me because i can protect i've got
control over that
i'm not against it i'd be open
but it's not something that i would seek
now and there was that day that you got
a chance to meet him yeah and what did
you find out that day
about him or why he wasn't present or
well i didn't really i didn't find out
anything
my mom had always told me this story
that sort of went like
bless her and this is what now i'm a
parent i'm like she was so thinking on
the spot but it's something that stuck
with me
she said
some some
daddies aren't very good at looking
after little girls because they would
look after little boy it's easier for
them to look after little boys and she
must have literally been doing the
washing and i've said why don't i just
you know
i like because at that time i i knew
that he had a son
fast forward to have many years later i
realized that you also had two daughters
so that sort of my mum was like
but at that point i was old enough to
like
realize that you know
he it just he had a new set up and i
just didn't slot into that i'm super
naive to the situation because i don't
know what it's like it's important to
say that so everything you talk about or
assume of the situation comes from a
place of like total naivety um
like if i'm if i met my dad and he
wasn't around i would assume i would
just like ask him the [ __ ] question
like where the [ __ ] have you been like
yeah
i know and can i just tell you with
everything else in my life
i am i mean ask anybody that knows me
the most direct person but there's just
this
like
i can't even
articulate it enough like there's this
weird
it's been my life right and i've got to
this point and i still don't know the
answer but i know the person that i want
the answers from isn't the person that's
going to give me the honest answer so i
just don't waste my own time because
time is something that we don't have
enough of so i'm at that place so it's
not that i'm like
i'm not scared to know the truth i'm not
like i'm just not in desperate need for
it because i know that that it's not
gonna be
a real picture of what happened and i'm
too old and i'm too wise to believe
[ __ ] so i think
that's where i am with it
there's something really powerful and
beautiful about acceptance in situations
like yeah
it seems that most of our unhappiness or
frustration comes from the lack of
acceptance not getting to the point
where we need the answer and we need
someone to blame well you need to be
like i'm not gonna be me having a
conversation with my father now at 32
years of age with three kids of my own
with a husband with my own career my own
life
me having a conversation and him saying
to me
oh
it didn't work out with your mum and i
and this i don't know what he would say
this is me thinking of an answer
me having that conversation i'm actually
not going to get anything out of it
that's genuinely how i feel there's not
anything he would be able to say to me
that could change the fact that he
didn't come to watch my nativity play or
he didn't do put in that ground
so really
i don't
need a dad at my age now
because i have my own family set up and
i'm secure
so i'm not seeking that because it's
something i've never had do you forgive
him for his absence
yeah i think i do i don't i'm like that
as a person i don't hold on and i think
if there was something in life that i
would hold on to it'd be something like
this right
because i would have the right to but i
don't and i think had you have asked me
at 18
i'd i would have i would have been like
i will never forget that man for not
being around for me but i just know what
it is
i know what i'm gonna get if i had
contact with him
and i accept it like you say acceptance
actually can be a beautiful thing and it
can be a liberating thing to think
i'm not
holding on to something that i can't
change it's done it's in the past it is
what it is
there's a quote that i read one day on
and it really stuck with me and it kind
of speaks to what you're saying there
which is um um
forgiveness but i guess acceptance as
well is letting a prisoner go and
realizing that you were the prisoner the
whole time so
you were holding on to a weight which
wasn't going to ever serve you but you
you thought it was in service of revenge
or victory i'll win if i hold on to this
grudge or this bitterness but in fact
it's like poison in your own chalice
honestly i couldn't
like i have
friends that they're
they are back to a t
and i think you have literally
you're you are stopping your future and
the rest of your life because you're
holding on to something that
first of all no one even knows what it
is when it's been that long like like
what is this all about and you're but
you're the person that remains unhappy
because you're
you're going through life with a side of
your brain that's focused on the fact
that well no because they've done me
wrong yeah they did you're doing
yourself wrong yeah amen it's like yeah
it's exhausting and that's just not me
as a person like
on to the next and that's just me that's
that's always been my mentality so you
on that day when you you discovered his
his other life his his life as it is you
also discovered um two
is it half sisters is that what it's
called i have no idea i don't even know
what an uncle is these days but yeah
yeah so yeah i suppose technically
they're half yeah we share the same
father but not the same mother yeah um
two sisters and a brother okay yeah
so i you're right i knew i had the
brother i didn't know that he had
daughters but obviously
they were young so they came with him
and we we just
weren't going to see eye to eye he just
wasn't
consistent
and that was just the you know
a continuous pattern
so then it sort of the contact dwindled
again to near or nothing
well nothing
and
then fast forward to
about 11 12 years later
i was at a christmas due at my then
agents
and they had just taken on
one of the guys from love island kemp
who is a lovely lovely guy
and
i obviously you know prosecco's hit
mom's got a night off have her having a
lovely evening
he randomly come up to me i've never met
him before prior to this never met him
i was like nice to meet you and he was
asking me about the management and was
like do you enjoy and i'm like yeah
they're going to be great for you good
luck with everything
and then i could feel that he wanted to
approach me and say something and the
night's gone on
and you know maybe a couple of cocktails
later he comes up to me and he's like
look
okay so this is really weird but i went
to school with your sister
i was like right okay really she never
said thinking the sister that i grew up
with
and he's like no
so on your dad's side
and he said i always said to her because
she was a really good friend if ever i
bump into your sister
i'm going to give her your number
and i lit can i just tell you
i was twisted
i sobered up within a second i was like
sorry what
and he said look can i just message her
now and it all just happened so quickly
he whatsapped her and was like i'm with
your sister a christmas party can i give
give her your number she was like please
the next thing i had
her number saved in my phone
the next day
i
sent her a message
we had arranged to meet later on that
week
with all of them so
so the two sisters the brother
so i was like okay this is great like
and i told my mum and and then it got to
thursday night and i promised you i had
the worst time like i was so nervous
i said marv i don't know if i can do
this i don't know if i can go like this
is
so i made him come with me really
so he came because i was like the three
of them are together they've grown up
with each other they know each other
like i feel really i don't know why i
just felt really vulnerable about the
whole thing
so yeah we went for dinner we it was
like
marv said it was really weird for him to
witness
because he was like i just felt like
it was the norm
and it was weird like i was like my
brother going you look like my eldest
daughter like you know just jeans are
really mad and like she's super tall so
i'm like she must get her height from
you it was just a really weird thing and
marvin was just like in the kind of way
homie was like i was just staring at
them all because you are all
so similar and
it's that weird like nature and nurture
thing isn't it like we are just so
similar mannerisms everything
and then from that day
we like talk every single day
i can't remember a time when i wasn't
in my life isn't that a gift
it really is and that's what i mean when
i speak of not holding on to
resentment not not holding on to because
you know me thinking oh well that's
lovely for them they live the life with
my with my dad and they seem to get the
attention and not holding on to things
that you actually don't know too much
about like
not holding on to those feelings of
anger towards
the fact that he wasn't around for me
because if i'd held on to that i
wouldn't have gone i met them for dinner
and struck up that relationship and i
wouldn't have real key players that are
in my corner now in my life and people
that i adore but that comes of age
as i said the younger me i've read
something on instagram that said i'm so
proud of how the older me and situations
that the younger me just wouldn't have
entertained and that is the key
of just not holding on to stuff that you
think you have to
because actually there is always a light
at the end of that tunnel and
my light is them and the siblings that i
didn't have around me that are now
everything to me you know
i've always contended with that with
um especially growing up with this idea
that i i assumed my family should be and
look perfect yeah and we go through so
much um like self-harm trying to make
our family as we see it in like
the movies
like home like i just need them to be
like this and act like this and so much
despair and misery when they fail to
meet that expectation and i i think
there's not enough people talking about
the fact that like
by the way your family don't get like a
free pass into your life you don't have
to fight forever to make the setup
perfect in fact you end up harming
yourself more than you gain from trying
to achieve that and i definitely noticed
that in my life so with me at some point
when i got a little bit older and maybe
a bit more secure i realized that like
just like everything else in my life
that too has to serve me
you don't get a free pass
like if you're going to be toxic and
you're going to be an [ __ ] to me
goodbye [ __ ] like i don't care
if we have the same you know i mean and
yeah that's not a narrative people talk
about enough so i was really
yeah and i think and i think for me i
definitely grew up
i grew up with the sort of
i don't want to say embarrassment
because i'm not sure if that is the
right word i suppose as a kid maybe it
was but
my family didn't look like everybody
else's so i knew i was very aware like i
knew my grandparents god dress
themselves
um from my dad's side but i grew up in a
white family
felt like i'd constantly have to explain
that my sister
didn't look like my sister but we were
sisters and you know she'd be the last
person in the room that you'd say that
was my sister because we don't look
anything alike
and
you know i was aware that i then had
a side of my family my black side that
i wasn't around and but i would but that
was still a big part of my life that
and i was very aware of how that looked
and i knew that i had siblings
that looked like me but my family was
just a bit of a big messy picture but
like with so much love like i had the
best upbringing my mum did
everything by me to raise me in the
right way and
she did a phenomenal job but i was
really embarrassed of how that looked
like i didn't see
a christmas commercial that had like
my family on on the ad but really
as i'm old as i'm older now and as i
said it does come with age i'm like
it's amazing like i have so many
different elements of my life
but yeah i always want to speak about it
and be open because your family doesn't
have to look like i met marvin and his
mum and dad have been married like 40
odd years
and
you know they they share the same dna
and it's all you know it's all very in
my mind how i would wanted my family to
look but everybody's family comes if
they're different problems their their
road hasn't been plain sailing and i
just think so it's something that i've
always spoken about because
it is what you make it at the end of the
day and i think
like you said if it serves you in the
right way then brilliant but also if
your family is perfect on the outside
and it's not serving you
then
you don't have to hold on to things that
you think you have to because you've got
that
ideal picture in your mind
and even a dysfunctional family can
teach you a lot of important lessons
about life and so really interesting
course it tends to be the case with my
guests that come here it's in fact often
the
the thing that made them different the
thing that made their family slightly
dysfunctional which leads to them having
wild success obviously sometimes or
becoming an anomaly later in life yeah
it seems to tends to be the case that a
little bit of a different start to life
causes a little bit of a different end
to life yeah you know what i mean
um and that's again
needs to be said there's always a
downside as well to that so we have
people here that are incredibly
relentless in their career because of
some insecurity from their childhood so
just understanding that and being
self-aware about that is um important
speaking of
tremendous successes the saturdays
when you look back on that phase of your
life how would you describe it now in
hindsight and now you're 32. oh my gosh
you know you look 22. i look back now
and i think the saturdays existed at the
perfect time in my life
like i was a young girl in
well i think
when i joined the group i was like
obviously it took a while for us to
launch
so i think i was 18 when we formed
and
what young
girl
doesn't want to be
in a girl band well i mean i'm sure
there are girls that don't but for me
it was the most incredible experience
when i look back now i think
we were actually really fortunate when i
see other girl bands and their fallouts
and the way that looked i think goodness
me yes we bickered but we bickered like
sisters we never had a row that was like
we just never had it we didn't we kind
of was all there for the same reason we
loved what we did and we had a respect
for that
so i feel blessed because when i look at
the history of girl bands
it doesn't always play out that way so
we had the best time if there was
something up we'd sort it out and that
was it done and it was only only really
ever a work thing so it'd be like i
don't like that i don't think that's the
right vibe for the video
or i don't think and that's the sort of
disagreement that's sort of where it
stopped
and then we always had this there was
five of us so we had the majority rules
rule
and it was and on that on the on the
time where you were in the two and not
the three
it was so annoying yeah so you'd be like
and it was one of those things because
you know you couldn't do anything about
it because that's we lived our life by
that so it is what it is and even if you
think your point is so valid you're in
the two so go back down
[Music]
um but yeah so i had a ball i was young
for a proportion of it i was single
you know i didn't have chill i just we
we traveled the world we performed
i had a bloody good time doing it so
when i look back i only actually
look back
fondly
so interesting because liam payne sat
here
from one direction before he arrived i
would have said the same what young guy
wouldn't have wanted to be in one
direction but then when he described how
turbulent that experience was and being
a young dude that comes out on stage
there's 150 000 people screaming at him
he then has to go back to his hotel room
straight after the gig and he's
basically locked in the hotel room
because there's tens of thousands of
fans screaming downstairs and doing that
over and over and over again for years
and years and years really took a toll
on him yeah obviously like also not
being able to walk down the street
without people coming up to him and
um and then the band ending and there's
almost that sense of like well what the
hell do i do now yeah
was there not it almost made me think
that there's a bit of a curse of being
in the public eye especially in that
context of a band and yeah and then what
happens after and yeah did they
experience i don't know i just after the
conversation with them i thought yeah so
glad i wasn't in one direction yeah i
think look i think one direction's level
and it was a global phenomenon right
and i've noticed
being married to mark there's a very
different level of hysteria when you're
in a boy band to a girl band like it's
just it's just different it comes with
the nature of this job the hysteria is
wild for boys
which i do think would come with a
different level of pressure i mean
there's pros and cons to both you know
when you're in a girl band it's very
visual and people are obsessed with how
you look and if you're the one that may
have enjoyed your christmas too much and
put on a bit of weight oh people are
gonna tell you or if you're the one that
kind of you know there's there's with
girls it's all very visual and i think
that's what
i think we can all say that we would
have found the toughest at one point
for us
our we didn't burst onto the scene right
so like we weren't like jealous or like
one direction
who went on x factor in its prime
and
gained this overnight momentum and girls
overnight want to wait outside their
house because there's one minute you're
a guy that's just turned up for an
audition and the next minute
you've got this pressure that you don't
know how to handle because no one's
taught you that so for us we did the
like
university gigs we did the
we we didn't have that
burst we really did
it was a
real sort of grind to get our single
played on radio and we
you know so for us it was kind of
every little bit of success meant so
much because
we would all at the time we'd be like oh
we should've just got an expert and we'd
say things like that because we think it
was so hard for us and we'd see these
groups that appeared overnight and we'd
be like oh my goodness we've been here
for years trying
um you know our dressing rooms would be
toilets because that's sort of that's
the level it was it wasn't it wasn't all
glitz and glamour
but
it worked that way in the end and we
were all on that same page and it was
kind of like you're only as strong as
your weakest member right so we were all
there we were all present we were always
on time and we really wanted it
we enjoyed it because as these things
happened or we got booked for
an amazing performance which was really
hard to get or we you know an appearance
or a jonathan ross chat show we were
like we've only bloody got jonathan ross
because we couldn't get on there the
single before because nobody was
interested however yes there were
massive downsides it's like a whole
merry-go-round and that's a downside
you're on a hamster wheel i think the
downsize is not
having control over your own life and
i'm a control freak i don't know if
you'll gauge that already
um
i like to know what i'm doing i'm like
that's me as a person
so there's time you know there would be
times and when
you'd feel responsible and because that
was always our sort of mantra like we're
in this together like one of us drops
off we let the other one down
if you weren't up to it the pressure
that you'd put on yourself to be up to
it for everybody else like i
had a layer and i came back to work
three and a half weeks later and
performed on national television like
with spanx up to my neck to try and hold
in the belly and like
this is gross for you but boobs leaking
because i'm like trying to navigate am i
breastfeeding on my not all because i
didn't want to let the girls down and
and
the fact that the label were like you've
got another single to release and i
think it just got to a point
where we became a bit more adult
and we all just were like
this has been quite a lot
you know and we're ready to sort of
wind down we never actually officially
broke up
there's probably someone in the record
label somewhere that probably would
still say that we owe them a single
we didn't officially break up because
there wasn't a need to because we love
each other and it's look we don't talk
every day because we spent so long of
our life together but i see one of them
tomorrow and it's like
we haven't not seen each other i think
we just got to a point where we were
like
we've you know we've grafted we've done
this now we're ready to sort of
just like there's things that when
you're in a group that you don't even
think about right because you're
in control of yourself in the same way i
am now but thinking about things like we
would all have to agree on the same day
off
well that's near on impossible because
you want to go
to see your friend in
i don't know whatever he's doing that
day and you and i want to do this and
i've actually got this
so it was those little things that
became
hard for me like i want to be off
because mars got down for work so can we
have friday well no actually because i
want and it naturally
it's going to just become a little bit
like okay let's pause on this for now
and we can all
go in our own lanes and that's sort of
how it ended and how it still is
as those priorities shift i guess and
you start to you know then i had a baby
yeah exactly i'm like you know and
that's
that became
everything
and
owner had already had a little one too
before i had a layer but it just yeah
there's a there's a switch isn't there
and you start to go okay we've done this
now for us so when's the reunion quite
some time
you know what i just can't imagine doing
it i'll be totally honest with you and
i'm always honest i just can't
and i've been there to see marvin on
side of stage doing the whole groupie
wife thing but i thought
i just
just feels like a lovely chapter that
ended for me and it was so lovely and i
will always speak of it fondly but
it just feels like a period in my life
that's done when you think about doing
it when you think about getting that
email and they say we're going to do a
tour reunion what what are the emotions
that come to mind
as in the sense yeah it just would feel
like
i just i've look i've got three kids and
there's so many things that i turned
down because it wouldn't work for my
life
and that falls into that
category like
my life's changed i have a business
there's no way i could be on tour
imagine the girls in the office would be
like oh she's at the o2 tonight like
we've got stuff to do you know i think
it's just it just wouldn't well i don't
think i'd remember the dance routines
the thought of doing it's all of the
like the actual
i love it and i feel like a bit of a
cool mum that i had that time
but it's not me now it's just not and i
think it's okay
do your kids realize that you're
in a
really well-known girl band elia does
but she doesn't care it's really sad
like i was i was showing her these
videos she cares to watch the videos and
that's quite nice
but i was telling her i was like you
know because she loves little mix oh my
god she is like the biggest little mix
fan you should tell her they copied me
and i was like literally i was saying to
her because when the little mixed girls
were on x factor we were on tour and
they come to one of our tour rehearsals
and
like asked for our advice so i was i was
saying this to a lady and i was like
what do you know actually
when i was telling this whole story they
they come to and i tried to find it and
there was a clip on youtube of them
coming to meet us and watching our
rehearsal it was like it's ancient this
clip
she was like
but why would they ask you for advice
go to your room be crafty
so in her mind because she she
understands i did it but she i don't
think she realizes but it's funny
because because she loves little mix i'm
like god she would probably love it if i
did that again you know like she would
probably love that
but
yeah i'm just not
there in my life anymore
and that isn't
there's no
that's not bad mind as me and my friends
would say it's just not
yeah not for me now
i've had so many people tag me on
instagram even on telegram and in my
twitter dms
in a picture of them starting their heel
journey and it's one of the most
amazing things in my life that i get to
do a podcast which of course needs money
to to fuel and i have a sponsor like you
who i genuinely believe is going to help
every single person
who starts their heel journey change
their life because this podcast the
central intention of this podcast is to
help people live better lives and we get
to sit here and i get to promote to you
a product which has not only helped me
change my life but it's going to help
millions of people and is helping
millions of people live a nutritionally
complete life it's so it's such an
incredible product and for me the reason
why it's incredible is because it gives
me my protein it gives me my vitamins
minerals it's plant-based it's low in
sugar gluten-free it does all of that in
a small drink that tastes good there are
other products there's foods there's the
hot and savory collection many other
things but for me
this ready to drink is the absolute
saviour of my diet throughout the week
where i'm moving at such pace
look i don't want to labor the point but
if you haven't tried you'll give it a
try and if you do
tag me instagram wherever you try it
give me a tag anyway
back to the podcast
you talked about starting a business
then you've got a business you run now
my little coco
tell me about that why why did you want
to start that business and obviously you
know being a mother of three wonderful
children starting a business especially
starting a business at the start of the
pandemic is a
uh really great time right yeah
phenomenal timing to take on tremendous
responsibility yeah so
obviously i'd started the business
before it didn't launch until a few
weeks before the pandemic hit
um
but there was an emotion right we
couldn't stop then
so i was pregnant
with a layer
and
going through that real phase of like
thinking i'm an earth mum
and being really precious about what i
use or my kid you know they are the most
precious thing
ever in your life like that just
and
i was really fussy about what i used
and i would shop really premium so i'd
be like going into like liberty beauty
hall and finding out you know and i'd be
really into it there wasn't anything
that existed on the high street that i
felt happy with you know a lot of them
have like outrageous chemicals in and
things that you
are like oh that's quite harsh for baby
skin so for me it was bridging that gap
of
products that you could use for the
whole family
that were gentle that had everything
that i wanted as you know my values
and
so the journey began and i didn't want
this to be
a flash in the pan thing i didn't want
this to be baby by rochelle humes this
wasn't about me right this was about me
building a brand
from the ground up
rolling with the punches which we
certainly have done and yeah bigger
picture you know
almost creating a space
i knew what i wanted to do but almost
creating a space for myself that like
i'm always going to be needed right
because it's mine and no one can make
the decisions that i can make because
this is my baby so why was that
important well i think i suppose there's
a little bit of the nature in what i do
that
yes i host television but
any day someone
more relevant or more current could come
along because that's the way the time is
there could be somebody new that now
fills the gap that i
you know had created or left open so i
think
for me it's always
being that one step ahead and being in
control being in control you're getting
this thing yeah um marvin told me
[Laughter]
um
it hasn't been easy though goodness to
me
so
i knew exactly what i wanted so
developed pro we started off with a
range of seven products um
that would develop which takes a long
time and please believe it's like
particularly when it's children involved
so the testing for any product the
process is quite
stringent and it's it's a full-on thing
but add newborn into it
we're dealing with a whole new level of
testing which rightly so
um
so it took a while it took three years
in you know for
before the pandemic hit and it was in
store it was three years work prior to
that
and i'm never happy with something on
the first round it's notorious it's not
happened yet it won't happen there'll
always be something that i want to
change
so that obviously took quite a long time
and then it was me
i suppose deciding from a sensible
business perspective if i want to
take the risk and go on my own
e-commerce first of all or do i want to
partner with a retailer
most people eventually want to partner
with a retailer right it's getting in
there and it's you know
and that's where i was lucky you know
the business has been me and it's been
my graft aside from rochelle humes but
that's where i do feel lucky that i
could use my profile to have a meeting
with certain retailers and
be in that room and you know
use that to my advantage which i did do
however it can go against me too so it's
not always
yeah okay you've got that because you
have had the profile that has helped
with that it actually can
can go against you because you know what
do you know you're a celebrity coming
into this world and what is this going
to be another celebrity range people say
that to you or was that kind of implied
yeah i mean they said it without saying
it as bluntly as i did yeah it was it
was yeah definitely implied
so then so i was going for a whole thing
and there was
i'd had this moment where
one of my products um was a cult well it
is a curl custard
and
that was key to the range like that's
happening
and
there were quite a few retailers that
didn't feel the need
they liked the range
i think they like the range and they
like the association with me and what
that might bring to
their store
but
the values and everything else that
comes with the brand that i've created
they wasn't so interested in
so the fact that i'm trying to make it
diverse
the fact that
you know that i want people to walk on
their high street and be able to get a
hair product for
afro hair
that that's a must the fact that you
know
the level of moisturizing is different
when you're of a black background
you know and that that appreciating
those things and i think
i mean what's really interesting is i
think if i'd have pitched this idea now
post blm movement
i think they would have bit my hand off
yeah yeah which is wild right
but when i did pitch it it was like now
there's not really i don't think there's
a need and i'm like there's no need for
a product for people with curly or afro
hair
sorry
what
so i
there was a bit of a struggle
and then i
had this meeting
with boots i actually felt like i was on
dragon's den really yeah felt like i was
on the telly
um
i actually was i was really nervous i
felt like i was really just
pitching
something that i knew that was great and
that i believed in but it was really i
suppose when it's your passion
it fills you with that level of nerves
that are different right
instantly
but it was boots they got it they were
like okay
love it we want to take it all
and we love the curl custard
and that's that okay these are my people
these are my people and it's i mean it's
ironic it's it's just i'm i'm so pleased
that i went with my gut and i was
persistent with that because i felt like
it was gonna go somewhere so i needed to
stand firm on that what else has
surprised you about running your own
business that you uh if someone had told
you before you started you might not
bothered
oh my gosh
it's all-consuming and i think if you're
gonna start a business you have to know
that don't think you're going to turn
your phone off at five because that's
not a thing
it's not a thing
and if you turn your phone off at five
don't expect a successful business
like don't expect to make money for the
first period of time expect to if you
break even that's good
and
you have to be all in
you can't like i i speak to like some of
my sister's friends and they want to we
want to start business
but you know do you
do you actually and i think it's it's
and that's not being patronizing that's
like you're not going to make an
instagram page for it it's going to be a
success overnight and you're going to
post a few pretty pictures it takes
everything
and i think
once you're happy with that
then i think you'll be okay once you
know that
it's really interesting um
because people don't talk about that
enough there's a definitely a culture of
be your own boss start a business as if
it will be you know the minute you make
that decision it's a decision of like
freedom and
your life is just
totally yours and in control but it
tends to be the case in my experience
anyway that starting a business becomes
almost the antithesis the opposite of
control yeah you you are controlled by
your emails and your whatsapps and
crisis and employees and
and i think it's important part of the
reason i started this podcast was to try
and shed a light on that that side of
things that instagram won't like
definitely tell you about and i think
that's because that's the
that is the culture that we live in now
that that
you literally can launch a page and you
can look something overnight it doesn't
mean that it's gonna
work
and i think
yeah i think i just i'm always real with
that sort of stuff because
you have to work hard like you it
people underestimate graft
and i think
particularly that's something that's
really important to me for my children
like
are they gonna have the same level of
hustle that i have and that same work
ethic and i still don't know the answer
to that to be honest with you do i do
that through schooling do i i really
make a fuss about their tests but i also
want to let them know at the same time i
didn't leave school with x y and zed i
did it myself so i think
that's an it's something that i just
look
show up be present
be committed
work your ass off at the thing that you
know that it is that you're good at
and i think i'm not into like i'm not
going to be that mum that lets my kid go
and expect if she can't sing and be
clapping in the wings i adore my
children
and i will love them no matter what and
i would like to hear them sing but i'm
going to be real and i think that's what
we need more of and i think that's what
because i'm everyone's hype girl to the
end i will hype you now i've met you and
i like you i will hype you so hard
but i will always be real with you and i
think that is what it doesn't have to
come up
you know from a place of judgment or a
place of disrespect it's like look
maybe go away and think about that a bit
more and go and i think that's what i
want my kids to have from me they'll
have love and abundance
but if if you're not good at a certain
thing i'm not gonna go do it and lead
them into a room blind i'm gonna say
look this is what you're amazing
actually look at this
and i think
we can love our kids and support them
without
you know
because i think that's doing them wrong
i think we can be real at the same time
a lot of our guests in fact have sat
here in in the last couple of weeks and
said the same thing about the importance
of actually don't focus on the [ __ ]
you're really bad at if you want to go
far in life don't try and turn your d in
physics to a c in physics just focus on
jimmy carter just focus on the a like
double down on the on the competency so
and it's that it's taking that like
focus
put your energy in in what you know
because you know what you're good at you
know what happens you get that you get
the buzz from it you know what sits
right with you you know
where you're aligned to go with that and
work on that because
that's sort of how i live my life
everything that i know that i'm not
people always said oh you should go into
acting
i'm like i can act up to marvel and i
need a couple of things but i'm not an
actor i'm not i know i'm not so i'll
just
why are we gonna do that the same way
when i left the group everyone was like
you're gonna release a solo album i work
well in a band i know my strengths i'm
not you know i'm not beyonce i mean i'd
love to be and i think i am after
tequila but that's a different story
but i know what i'm good at i'm a good
talker
so
you know media and television that's my
route that's something that i'm
passionate about so and everyone for
ages was like i bet she's in the studio
and i bet she doesn't want to tell us
and i bet she's doing a solo album i'm
like i'm bloody well not because guess
what i've i've taken what i need from
this experience
and i got away with it in a band and yes
i you know i can sing
i'm not the best singer in the world i'm
really not and guess what the charts are
full of amazing singers so let me do
something that i know
that i can deliver and i work my ass off
at that
what you're describing there to me
sounds it's really interesting because
you're describing like pursuing the
thing where you have a degree of
competency you're good at it but also
where you have like that internal
intrinsic passion yeah and like both are
so important i actually spoke to a girl
the other day on a zoom mentoring call i
was doing and she'd gotten to a stage in
her life where she just just and this is
where the passion bit's really important
she kind of just followed the the
opportunity so she was good at let's say
maths so she found herself at 35 as
being this accountant
but she actually
never cared about maths she didn't care
about being an accountant she got
dragged by
the the opportunity it's like you saying
okay i'll do the single just because i
can or i'll do my solo career just
because i can i'm not taking that moment
to pause and go actually what is it that
i care about and regardless of the fact
that i can do it do i want to do it yeah
and of money and
is this carrot that sometimes can lead
us to make short-term decisions which
become long-term regret right and i've
definitely done that yeah i've
definitely done that i've definitely
thought
i've done i've done it with brand work
before definitely
i've taken on a brand project
and
known it's not really me but the money
was so bloody good welcome to my world
i will take all the deals
but i've got to the do you know what i
think i've got to that point now well
yes and it does again come with age it
comes with i suppose
more financial stability than i had
before like i left the group and people
were
and i wasn't sure what was going to
happen right because i'd left this group
where my life was planned to a tea for
me
and then i was going it alone and i
thought well that's good money i should
take it i don't know what
and hi i'm michelle humes and this is
sausages i don't know whatever
and
i've definitely done that and i'm not
ashamed to say it and yes with i suppose
more
now financial stability
it's it's easier to be choosy right so
this is now easier for me to say because
at the time it was like well i don't
know when you know
when the next one might be you know the
next deal might come in
and do you know even more so in the last
sort of 18 months
if i and this is with everything it's
now i'm so
it's the no's that are not more
important to me than the yeses
and
look i come from a working class
background where my mom has always been
like make hey where the sun shines like
this is amazing but i've really sort of
flipped the switch on that now
and
said to myself do i feel it
i put myself in this situation this is
actually mentally what i do you're gonna
laugh so
if i get a phone call about something
and something's come in or because i
have my five-year plan of stuff that i
know that i would like to do
and we will work to make that happen but
some you know
we're also reactive so people might call
and say we thought about michelle for
this and this would be great
and i actually pretend
that i'm interviewing
myself
on the sofa on this morning and i have
to promote it no do this because it's
actually mad so if i was interviewing
you about i don't know you
you now
are being the face of this mug right
could you
sit on the safer and i'm not so tell me
everything so why did you want to do
this could you genuinely say it with
your gut
and feel passionate about it and believe
in it and know it works and feel proud
of that association
and there are those checklists that i do
in my mind and the questions that i
would ask someone so tell me about it so
when did this start when did you get the
phone call how exciting is it and if i
don't feel confident in that interview
i'm not doing it and that is my new
thing and for the past sort of year
that's what's been playing out in my
mind
and it's changed the landscape for me
that's such a i love that i think that's
so powerful because what it did for me
then is i was trying to think about the
ways to sell this mug right
i saw your face you weren't selling it
and this is your mug in your house by
the way i'm buying you some christmas
well i think i think you look closely
actually matches the table so there was
it does but you don't believe in it i
can tell no
i said to myself i think i could do it
once but then getting called to and to
build a business or to pursue something
you have to do it over and over and over
again for an indefinite period of time
maybe 10 years i couldn't do it for 10
years the first time we'd be acting we
can all act in the short term if we have
to but acting for a sustained period of
time does all kinds of damage i mean
eventually it's going to become really
hard to get out of bed to do something
i'm not passionate about and it's not
just acting the wants because then it
turns into the whole new world now which
is social media yeah so then which i
treat my social media like my home right
i keep it tidy i keep it nice if someone
wants to come in i'll make sure i've
tidied up the place so my pictures are
good but you know and i you know i try
to
visually i'm you know i'm honest
but i also like it looking nice i'm not
going to post the worst part of my day
and i have respect for people that do
and i say this a lot because i think
there's become a pressure with social
media that we now have to be honest
constantly and i should be displaying my
stretch marks at all times and i should
be saying
my child's just
you know i don't know had a really messy
nappy in front of everybody and they're
bombed on me and i've got to take a
selfie and document that moment i have
respect for you if you can do that but
i'm too busy getting myself out of the
[ __ ] at the time that the last thing i'm
thinking about is a selfie do you know
what i mean so i i really
i fee so i think there's now a pressure
that we all have to take that approach
which is interesting that we should be a
politician we should come comment on
current affairs like look
i have a blue tick for the reason that
you know for the reason that i'm
verified and it's not because i'm a news
anchor and it's not because i know
everything that's going on in the world
and it's not because
you know i'm constantly going to expose
every part of my life and
but i'll be the real me on there but i
just can't if something bad is happening
at home
i might be ready to talk about it in a
week but that's the sort of instant
instagram for me so i think it sounds
like you've had a couple of dms of
people pushing you to talk on things
well i think i think but i think you
yeah you do and i think it's not just
dm's i think people just expect and i'm
also really aware of that i call it the
blue tick responsibility i'm really
aware of the fact that people could
take my information and it it might not
be correct so i don't want to become and
i think there was a lot of that over the
pandemic people reposting stuff before
they knew the right information and then
i've i've then
become part of that scaremongering
culture and i feel
i feel it's my responsibility to report
on stuff that i know everything about
and the stuff that i know everything
about is myself
my brand my right so i think don't
expect
that from people that are
also not in the know yeah yeah i think
it's quite a it's quite a big ask
actually
and obviously there's a lot i'm
passionate about and that might
you know that might muddle into you know
if i know about it and i've got an
opinion on it yeah i'm going to tell you
but i'm not going to talk about
something that i don't know about i
don't think it's fair
let's talk about that then things you're
passionate about um and
sort of topics you've you've spoken on
the black maternity scandal was one of
those topics um
i was i was reading about why you wanted
to do that documentary and the
statistics around um
mortality in the black community at
pregnancy are pretty staggering for me
yeah the thing that i found really
i want to talk to you about particular
was there was a bit of a a conversation
when you decided to do that documentary
around whether you were black enough
let's
it was quite it was quite the
conversation let's just call it how it
is
and i find it we've both got i believe
i'm guessing here a white parent and a
black parent as well correct it's
interesting because growing up in an
all-white school i was blacker than
black yeah i was the blackest thing
anyone had ever seen
i was the nice guy and then when you go
into
adult life and
you also seem to get then rejected by
the black community even though you've
spent your whole life thinking and you
know yeah being the blackest person in
in my circle and i i funnily enough i
was posted on um
an instagram account when i was
announced as a dragon and the debate in
the comments section from this kind of
like black instagram account was all
around whether i was black enough
and it was black people saying well
that's enough for what for what i don't
know to like be part of that community
like i'm too much of a lighter i don't
even know what that means i'm apparently
i'm too much of a lighting to be
um
to be part of that community and i just
think
i have to say and i just don't give a
[ __ ] because no one could find me i just
think it's pathetic i think personally i
think it's totally [ __ ] pathetic like
black people trying to decide whether
i'm black enough
to to understand like my mother is
nigerian i was born in africa what do i
have to like what do i have to do to be
able to speak to yeah look i i'll be
honest with you i found that really hard
and i actually found that probably the
hardest thing that i've come across in
my
career
i found it really
it's our background on that before we
come to this so as you said so at the
time of filming the show
um there was a campaign started um by
two brilliant women um called five times
more
and black women were five times more
likely to die in and around childbirth
than their white counterparts
and if you what we say black and brown
women but if you were from a mixed
background so i was
four times as likely if you were
if you were of an asian background you
were three times as likely and it
basically if you weren't white
it didn't look good for you in and
around childbirth
so
i got approached by a production company
to go on this sort of
journey into why
and
at the time they asked me i was very
pregnant
and
i just was like it's a little bit too
much i found it a bit overwhelming i was
also scared about working
um during covid and that you know at the
peak of kobe 2.6 we're very much still
living through it
um
because if you were pregnant you were
also at more risk and then obviously if
you're of a black background and
pregnant you're at more risk of getting
covered and also it was so i was just
like look i'm going to be in my house
i will 100
because this was just a pitch at this
time right and you know how this works
you can make a million different
programs but none of them necessarily
make it on telly so i said look if you
think you put my name on this pitch to
channel four is going to get it across
the line put my name on it but i'm in
the new year once i've had the baby in
october
get let me just i will i would i'm here
for it i will do it
so that conversation happened
they said yes we would want to
commission it
we'll wait for you all to do in the new
year so that was that and then
fast forward to
we announced that we were taping it
which was probably we'd already started
but we were announced because i think i
wanted to get a couple more
women that i'd found through my channel
to maybe share their experiences
and so i sort of did a call out on
social media i announced i was filming
it and did a call out to to say this is
what we're filming and it sparked a
conversation it's back to a real
conversation of did you know and a lot
of people were like yes what you know
white midwives had messaged me saying
i've seen this you know i would i'd like
to be a part of it you know there's a
there's lots that needs to be needs to
be done here but first and foremost
people didn't know those stats and i
think that was
for me really important that we we get
that
on a big stage
there's some women that have been doing
some incredible work for years working
tirelessly
um to promote these figures and to
you know
get some sort of acknowledgement that
this happens
so let's give it a big voice right
so first of all the conversation was and
that was the feeling everyone was like
well done i didn't know about this
and then overnight the doll turned
there was a post that was posted on
instagram that was from another woman
who is
an author
um
a presenter that said that she
had been asked
to front the same show
so this conversation has happened and it
was like great and then
she had said i'd been asked to front
this show
which obviously i'd woken up and seen
this post and was mortified she was a
darker skinned black woman
the first thing i did
was dm her
this is my number i don't know what [ __ ]
has gone down here but this is my number
give me a call
to this day i've not heard from her
and then that sort of triggered this
whole conversation of
the fact that i'd taken a a darker
skinned woman's bread and it it
the dial switched overnight and i was
can i tell you i was beside myself
devastated because first of all that
isn't i'm not whether you're white black
i'm not stealing any woman's bread
that's not for me so i kind of wanted to
get to the bottom of this so i called
channel four i caught i was like just
tell me has anybody because i was on the
pitch right so i was like this is
bizarre because we pitched this together
has anybody been asked to host this
apart from me because i'm not cool with
this and this isn't i'd i'll do it with
her we'll do it together but this isn't
the way that i work
and she and she hadn't been asked and
obviously
as i said there's lots of shows that are
being made so i'm not sure if there was
another production that she'd maybe had
word with and maybe started making
something similar that i that i don't
know and it's probably more than likely
so obviously it sparked this debate
around colorism which
is also a great conversation to be
having we don't have that conversation
enough
but it wasn't the debate we were trying
to spark we were talking about maternal
mortality so it sort of snowballed into
this chat and colorism most definitely
exists i'm aware of that i might be
lighter than one woman but i'm
definitely darker than some that's how
my life has been
so
in a way i was like look
this is at my expense
and this conversation that sparked is
incorrect and it isn't
this isn't how it went down
however it sparked a conversation that
i'm not gonna
release a statement and stop it and say
listen it wasn't and i'm not gonna out
another woman for saying the wrong
information because that isn't me so i
let it i let it go because i just
thought do you know what
that's also a conversation worth having
yes to some i definitely have it a lot
easier because
i am lighter skinned
but as i said before i'm also darker
than some so i understand it so i let
that conversation play out for that
reason because the more we talk about
these things the better right
however it was harsh and it was a hard
pill to swallow because in this instance
this isn't it wasn't it
i felt really hurt because
i was
first of all i was being denied of my
black gene
yeah first off
secondly the community that i'm making
this show for and that we were fighting
to get this on tv it was the first
documentary of this kind being made
weren't happy about it until they saw it
and i was like just wait and see it
because it's actually not about me it's
about the brilliant women that have been
brave enough to take part in this dark
so yeah it was a really weird period of
time because i genuinely didn't know how
to handle it because i didn't i then put
the show on the other foot and then i
said okay so if i'd been asked to do
this which i had to do this show put my
name on it to get this commissioned
and i'd said no if you think it's going
to get commission but we really feel
rushed that by putting your profile to
it we'll get it across the line and if
i'd have said no
am i not then doing my bit for the back
am i not then doing what i should be
doing and
so i really imagine it was a yeah
imagine imagine imagining that that
story broke michelle was asked to do
this um documentary about um
the increase in the the staggering
statistics of mortality in black women
at childbirth and she said no
imagine that you would have got the same
this is a lose-lose situation
and that's how it really felt and i
think that was the biggest frustration
and also in all of this
so this big conversation happened
fine okay i get it and i'm not saying
that colorism doesn't exist because it
really [ __ ] does and it's awful and
it's unjust and it isn't right and
there's a lot of work to do
in that space and i think that'll be
something that exists for a very long
time unfortunately
however
that
it wasn't it and it wasn't right to make
this situation about colorism
and yeah i just found it a real struggle
because at the same time and there was a
lady called mars who's just a brilliant
woman she's a doula and she has been
campaigning
for this disparity for a very long time
and she said the thing that you're
forgetting she called me because she saw
it all go down she was like are you all
right are you okay
and i literally burst into tears
she was like you're forgetting
you've you've lost yourself out of these
stats
because being a mixed woman
you are still four times as likely to
die than a white woman you're losing
yourself in this too and your children
and the re
so you are still very much part of those
stats so let's not lose this here you
know these the stats are about black and
brown women
so i had to remember and there was talk
of we had a meeting at my management and
we go we're going to pull out of this
should we just pull out of this because
and i was like no do you know what i'm
not
because it's not actually about me and
they will learn that when this program
airs
because these brilliant women have
trusted me to protect their stories we
were so careful we had we had one
director a black female director and it
was just we didn't have a soundie we
didn't have any a whole crew
we turned up to these women's homes and
we protected we wanted them to feel safe
so it was just her and i
and they could tell their story and we
didn't want to sort of
make them relive their trauma in a way
that wasn't going to be helpful so we it
was we we did it in the best way that we
could um
and what's interesting is
i've had so many different letters since
saying i'm so sorry that we wrote this
article because
actually we watch the show and it's not
what we so it's just funny that when i
talk about that blue tick responsibility
one post can set a whole community
alight
when actually it was incorrect
and
that's where i think we all need to do
better in our position to make sure that
we're always posting the right
information when we do that
social media is is very much a place of
um trying to hold everybody
to a standard of fit like false
perfectionism like as if we're all just
perfect human beings we make perfect
decisions there is correct and there is
wrong on social media there's no nuance
there's no middle ground there's no
appreciation for like
complexity and how okay this is right
but also this is right that that
conversation doesn't happen because
we're the algorithm pushes us into these
tribes where we're either left or right
um
when you're trying to be
true to yourself when you're trying to
um speak on issues that matter it's
almost it's almost impossible in in the
age of social media and what i
really like about what you've described
there is um there was this intense
pressure to like fall in line with
correct with what when i say correctness
i don't mean that it's right i mean like
they're like false correctness this is
you know it's like a mob screaming in
your face rochelle this is correctness
stop do come and join us yeah on the
side of false perfection and come and
and you had the i guess the i wouldn't
even describe it as courage because that
doesn't feel like the right word but you
had the sense to say i'm gonna do this
anyway
um a lot of people don't have that these
days a lot of i find it so incredibly
hard like
i'm someone who's probably at some point
going to get cancelled because i really
when you describe that story to me it
just pisses me off so much yeah but you
have to sit on it i know and i but with
this it was different because of the
reason i was doing it yeah so i was like
look i don't want to say anything
because there's a lot of noise happening
and i've not even said anything yet yeah
and my the old me with what we were
talking about would have just gone
yeah but really i didn't want
if i spoke on it it would be another
daily mail article and the noise would
have just it would just kept
you know snowballing out of control
so
i was just like look i'm not do it this
isn't about me it's not about me it's
about
i had a job in my mind and my mind and
that's what kept me going because those
women that i spoke to i was it was for
them
and the whole time i was checking they
were okay with this look do you think
and i was getting their their take on
this and if they had said to me at one
point rush i actually think
maybe stepped down from this
i would have done genuinely i would have
done but they had trusted me and i i'm
not going to let them down we're
thinking about the bigger picture here
and i think so it was that so i just i
just kept silent on it because i thought
what is it the queen you don't ex do
like the queen if someone said to me
once you you never
you don't explain and you don't complain
in certain situations i was like i've
never done like the queen in my life but
i'm going to put it to use right now
because
i didn't want to make it about me i
didn't want to make it about the fact
that do you know what actually i was
scared of taking my kid to nursery that
day because i got death threats i didn't
want to make it about do you know it's
not about me
it was about the bigger picture and i
think
i just had to hold on to that marv did
take my phone off me that day i lost my
i lost my for the weekend he was like
that is going off and he literally texts
everybody that works with me and was
like
if you need him here but like no more
phone
you're right if you had responded it
would have been fuel for the fire i
think when those moments happen people
are intent on misunderstanding
that's what it feels like they are tr so
even if you'd come with your explanation
honestly the lens in which they would
have viewed your explanation or your
side of the story is like where can we
find another [ __ ] twist exactly and i
thought you know what a num it's
it's too tiring and then if i say
something then someone like you said
would yeah but you still didn't and then
i would have had to have gone back to
that and i think it's a never-ending
yeah it's a never-ending cycle but that
that definitely was like
navigating through that was probably the
hardest
thing i've actually been through ever
would you would you
if you could now erase that experience
and not have going through it would you
yeah you would erase it yeah
i'd erase the i wouldn't erase doing the
show and doing i would have raised that
day and that
that it was just awful but didn't it
teach you something
because you'd be erasing the lesson it
taught you as well if you raised the
experience yeah you're right you are
right
yeah
i'm gonna give you an eraser would you
erase that day no
a little bit
just just just touch it up a little bit
um no do you know what i think
i think you're right and i actually
think that happened at the start of this
year and do you know what you was we
were saying like over the past year my
whole
outlook has changed on a lot of things
and maybe you're right maybe it has
also come
from experiences like that that have
taught me
not to you know not to react so quickly
and not i think sometimes we're so
quick to jump out to our own defense
because i don't want someone to think
i'm that person and i don't want them to
think that i would do that to another
woman guess what i know i would never do
that to another woman that isn't me the
first thing i did when i saw that was
message her and say babe here's my
number call me
because that isn't me
but do i need to defend that to a whole
lot of people that have already made up
their mind
no because it's exhausting and
i'm not achieving anything so i think
sometimes we're so desperate to to
defend ourselves and put out a statement
to say actually this isn't what happened
and you know
justice yeah
cause it sounds a lot like what we
described with the relationship with
your father
that need for justice ends up being
really self-harming yeah and accepting
acceptance again is the yeah and because
i know i was coming from a place of love
i was coming from the best place in the
world
people were saying things like oh yeah
you just you've got you've got enough
money give it to a presenter that didn't
have that opportunity i'm like i didn't
take the money from the show that's what
you don't know i gave it to the charity
in order that i was working with i
didn't take a penny from that event if
anything it cost me money
so
but was i going to write that in a
statement and to make myself look like a
you know look like the angel no because
it wasn't about me and i think sometimes
it is just taking that like you don't
have to jump to your defense to prove
that you're an incredible person all the
time
it's just i know where it was coming
from and sometimes it's enough and it's
exhausting because someone's always
going to have something to say always
always
especially on social media always yeah i
i i i've gotten to the place where i can
open my dms and i'll be reading it and
it'll be like love the podcast you're
amazing another podcast you're amazing
and then one guy goes make these
podcasts are proper [ __ ]
and you look at it and you go like do
you laugh now i do yeah i'll screenshot
it
we're shutting down the podcast brian
from skunthorpe with like a egg avatar
has
decided
i know but this but this is exactly it
right and there was that
that time when that prudent i turned
everything off
i turned off comments i turned up um
and then i just like i'm not dealing
with this i'm just gonna live my life i
literally
cried
for 48 hours and was devastated
it was really weird i made a roast
dinner
marv had my phone
and then i remember him that week going
well i think you can be you're all right
now on this because i i was like right
let's let's cancel filming this week
because i also didn't want it to affect
the contributors thinking oh we now
can't be part of this show
which we thought we were because now
we're worried the black community don't
approve of you know it means there was a
bit of that so i was like look let's
stop filming this week
and we'll go back to it when we all have
had some sleep and we don't feel too
emotional and
so that's what we did we picked it up
the following week so i took that week
off
and
rebecca that works with me she
marvin was on the phone today said right
can you just do me a favor before you
give it back so just clear the dms
and then she was actually like look it's
actually not as bad as you think and
whatever whatever it you know it's fine
we move we know the intention
and she sent me a screenshot of one of
my messages it was like you're cancelled
to me you're this you're that you're you
know
what you know there was a few of them
and then it was like
uh can you just tell me the recipe to
your roast potato
and then the next one would be like i
had so much respect for you before but i
can't believe what you've done and then
it would be like
um where's your dress from when you were
so it was you know it's just like do you
know what that is just
and i also think it was that period of
time where everybody was locked down
and it was like
everyone was on their phones more which
became like everybody came out and it
was like it felt just like such an
attack
i was like do you know what the reality
is
sometimes you're not going to get
everything right and
deep down i really don't think i would
have handled anything differently
because i know where it came from and
the place
but you're not always going to get
everything right and not everyone is
always going to be impressed with
everything you do and i think that was
maybe
maybe that's why it was the hardest time
because maybe it was the first moment
in my career that blindsided me
that i wasn't in control of that someone
could have said something that wasn't
quite the truth and i had no control
over that
and
yeah so maybe that's why i found it
because i wasn't you know normally i'm
like
i know what i'm doing i go on telly i do
my thing i do this or i've released a
single and it come
but i just didn't know i could
yeah
that that was possible and i think
that's probably why it got me in the gut
you talked a little bit there about
earlier about um you said made a comment
that you've never had one like this when
describing marvin and i can see there
you know he's doing a lot to shield you
and protect you by taking your phone and
kind of being a human shield from a lot
of that
chaos
um and you also said earlier in the
conversation that your business is
all-consuming yeah so how do you find
that balance because i'm i'm in a
relationship now and i struggle with the
balance of
do it being my professional steve and
all that stuff and then having to like
switch off and fall into a different
mindset where there's no like kpis and
it's not about profit and like you know
my girlfriend just wants to do simple
things watch movies watch something
about ayahuasca and peru like and i i
have to kind of compartmentalize
but like how have you and you've had a
you know
outside looking in again it's important
to say that because we
never know what's going on yeah we
talked about families so
it looks like you guys have had a really
solid relationship how have you achieved
that how do you find that balance and
what's what's the key i think we just
have this real understanding of one
another
and i think
we we both really appreciate how lucky
we are
like
that's something that we always say like
i can say it from my point of view
because i feel very lucky to have him
i'm not gonna
say why he's lucky to have me
but why is he lucky to have you
i'm joking
well
um
no so i can only speak for me but it's
something that we always agree on like
he really is my calmness in the chaos
like if that makes any and he always has
been he's got that real calming demeanor
and
he really is that for me so we've always
we've always both had a real respect of
how lucky
we are in this world that it's kind of
like
that we are in to find somebody that's
solid like i know how rare that is
have we nailed balance
babe no
we have three kids we have full-time
jobs we're self-employed
we're winging it pretty much through
life
but never with each other
he makes me feel really secure you know
and i think that is
something that's really important to me
and i don't know if that's where my dad
comes into play too
where that like he
like we could be anywhere in the world
but if we're together in our little
family this evening before we had kids
like
i'm like happy i'm i'm good with life
and i and i feel like that's why i can
i'm in a place
i'm not going to give him all the credit
actually here but i'm in a place where
in my career i feel like i can take a
lot on like when i arrived today i was
like i'm not good i've not stopped but
i've got i've all
that side of my life feels very
content and is content
which can push me on to do other stuff
and when i say like i look he'll always
be like oh my god it's amazing that
you've done this or that
and people will talk about well i
yeah it's great but i've got
i've got good people behind me you know
and and he is definitely at the
forefront of that for sure
you were you talked about how you were
cheated on a previous relationship
often when people are go through that
when they've gone through that kind of
deception and dishonesty from a partner
they go into the next relationship kind
of holding holding it the next person
like responsible for the last person and
i see that a lot of my dms i had this
conversation the other day and i don't
normally respond to this kind of thing
but she this
this um this woman had sent me her
screenshots with her boyfriend and she
was hammering him going show me your
phone
and then she explained to me she'd been
cheated on in the past so she's insecure
and she actually said to her her current
boyfriend like i think it was
guilty until proven innocent and i was
like no honey no
i was like you're going to do so much
damage by yeah to the foundation of the
relationship by bringing that but it
goes back to what we were saying again
you do damage to yourself
because now she is feeling
that she constantly has to be that
person
but who's happy here because the
boyfriend isn't happy doing that and she
really isn't so i think that was a real
conscious decision for me to not take
that into this
because i don't think you can ever let
any relationship grow its full potential
if you're still dealing with old [ __ ]
and that's in friendships that's in
the workplace but i think
yeah for me that was really really
important and
like anybody
until someone gives me a reason
to feel a certain way
like i'm not going to meet you and think
oh i met someone the other day that
interviewed me and was a bit of a dick
so this day is going to be horrendous
because sorry what was that i mean
you're a person
you're a lovely guy and we've had a very
nice chat um but do you know what i mean
like you can't walk into every situation
thinking because you had a bad time one
day that it's going to be the same the
next and i think
that's what i was really i will say when
i met mark i was very anti-getting with
him didn't they tell you not to get with
someone in a boy band and yeah anyway
yeah i did really not eat me and frankie
they were like it's really going well
girls you know
you've worked well the singles are going
down well
the worst the only thing that you could
do now
you know afterwards work so we didn't
have that overnight success as i was
saying the only thing you could do
because it's a really hard thing to get
girls to like girls girls love to be
fans of boys and boy bands the only
thing you can do to mess it up now
you've got the girls on side is to date
someone from boy groups
and you thought and i just remember
looking at frank cat was in this meeting
at the record label she was at the time
she was dating dougie from mcfly
and i was obviously dating marv and i
was like
well we [ __ ] this one
so it was kind of like we tried to keep
it a secret for so long and i remember
like sneaking into one of marv's gigs
and i was watching from the sound desk
and a girl come up to me and she said
you have ruined my life
i was like oh
i think i know what he meant the other
day
she was like like with intent like she
was like you have ruined
my life
and i was like huh like okay you know
it's like i couldn't really hear and
then but the third time i was like oh i
totally understand and the eyes i knew
what she meant
like i remember being like that's mad
because she wanted marvin yeah
and i remember thinking
oh okay then this isn't going to be
straightforward
but now the other side
all these years later reunion tours
i don't get that anymore
i don't get that anywhere else and now
i'd be like well babe listen you've got
to contend with snoring you've got to
deal with it i'd give him a list of
reasons why i've probably helped your
life
what's he like as a father
oh the best
like
do you know what's mad is i kind of
when i when i speak about this it's it's
a really weird thing that sometimes sits
with me odd
and not because of
my dad and my childhood actually because
we spend a lot of time going
as a society people will say
you're so lucky marv is such a good dad
and i'm like uh-huh he is and my
children are lucky to have a good dad i
get that totally get it because i didn't
have that i really get it but at the
same time there's always a part of me
that goes
he's doing what he should be doing
and we do all that oh it's daddy daycare
today
no he's just taking his kids out no one
says it's mummy daycare today or it's
well they're lucky to have a good mum
because it's assumed you should be a
good mum right
you should be a good mum you should be
able to have a career
you know
be
be a hot a hot girl for your fella
you should
be an amazing there's a lot of pressure
that's put on women
in that perspective i really really
think so and i think so yes he is an
amazing dad and he is devoted and he is
patient and he is everything i'd want
him to be
everything that i would have wanted for
you know of a dad
but really at the same time i'm like no
guess what he's stepping up to the plate
and i'm not taking anything away from
him because i really appreciate him and
we really do in my house he's a rock but
at the same time it's we live in this
weird
world where it's like you get a clap for
being a great dad
but if you're a mom and you're working
you're like oh she's out to work is she
not going to make the nativity on time
you know there's that like judgment for
doing what dads do if you're a mum it's
a really weird concept and it's
something i wasn't aware of until i had
kids
so true i've actually never thought
about that before but that is so
incredibly true it's like a dad is
giving a trophy a few daddy daycare he's
taking them out again for the day
unbelievable
i literally did that every day this week
but no one said anything
you know it's bizarre it's bizarre to me
earlier on you said you talked about a
five-year plan
yeah so what is the michelle hume's
five-year plan
so in career it would be
tv
i feel like i've got
enough
i feel like i don't want to i'm don't
want to saturate myself with stuff so
i'm trying to find a real balance of
there not being an announcement every
other week of something else i'm doing
and i'm so excited to announce now do i
i'd like balance so i would i love the
fact that me and marvin have a show
together that's a saturday night
entertainment show which is a family
show which is music it couldn't be it
couldn't be more perfect for us
i love that so i would love that to run
until the end of time
i love what i do when i dip in and out
of daytime television that suits me in
terms of my business i want it to keep
growing at the rate that it is
that's really important to me
i obviously now manage myself which is a
very different thing and that was
something that was really crucial in my
five-year plan tell me why you made the
decision to move away from external
management and to manage yourself and
what does it mean to manage yourself
i've got my manager in the corner there
so
sell me on the upside
this could get bloody awkward
so i i could never do it so i
i've been in this industry in
different forms
since
i was 12 years old so i was in scope
juniors when i was 12. i then did
presenting for kids television and then
obviously went into the group and then i
went back into telly after the group
ended
um
so i've always
a level of guidance throughout this
because it's something that we all need
it's a crazy world right
but i've always
sort of been at the mercy at some of
somebody else
and i think i've been really lucky over
the years to work with some of the best
management
teams
in the industry i really really have and
i feel there was a time where i was
desperate to be managed before all of
this i want a manager and i want to
maybe they can make this happen for me
and then
i got to a point where i feel like
in terms of tv
in terms of what i do for branding or
for how my job looks
i feel like
i'm not trying to build a name for
myself anymore in the sense of
a lot of the execs that these the
channels know me they know what i can do
if they want me for a certain thing
they're going to book me and yes i will
always pitch ideas and i'll have my own
ideas and they might take them or they
might not but i got to a point
where i feel like
in terms of that i'm happy in what i'm
doing
and really
nobody knows me better than i know
myself
it felt like a new challenge i felt like
i didn't want to be part of a big
corporate firm where people it takes
people quite a while to get an answer
whether i want to do x y and z i'd like
someone to be able to
speak to me or one another
and
i i could tell you when i'm on a
whatsapp ralph says thank you you want
to do no no don't waste your time let's
not take months to work up and offer and
present it to me because we've wasted
everybody's time so i wouldn't have done
it anyway
so i just felt like i got to a real
point where
it sounds like control
it does doesn't it it really does
consistent things it's what this podcast
is what this episode is going to be
called
control um but it really was actually
gaining that control back
like i didn't want to keep being advised
of what someone thinks i should do it's
not like okay
you have a very clever business and a
clever firm there's a lot of numbers and
a lot of things i don't understand but
it's not like somebody's saying to you
this is what we need to do because of
xyz and this is how this is moving so we
need to go this and this is the market
we need to dominate
really people advising me on me because
my business is me
so
i know how i know what my vibe is
because i am the vibe i'm the verb yeah
um
so i think i just got to a point where i
thought it's time to empower myself
and trust in that because there were
ideas being thrown around i'm like oh no
this isn't
oh this is so far off of me
so
yeah i had a real realization and
it was quite an emotional thing too
because it felt like a weird sort of
like a break up like
you know we've had a really good road
but i don't want this in the same way
anymore and it felt more that was the
hardest thing to do because i don't i
don't like upsetting people and
and we've built friendships over the
years which i hope still remain and i'm
sure they will
but it was that that was harder than the
actual decision which told me everything
and you know what some of this is your
fault
uh thank you for coming rachelle we had
a great podcast i would like to say
thank you for clicking around because
you've said something and i think you
don't listen to what i saw no i did i
watched
you talking and you said
who had you'd met someone you met obama
oh you spoke to i couldn't find 51
that
and i was like this is it and i
literally the next day i i called them
the next day
so it's actually sort of your fault
so the context on that is when i saw me
and obama both spoke on the same stage
in sao paulo um a couple of years back
in brazil and one of the things he
talked about on stage was when he had to
make the decision whether to take out
osama bin laden or not they didn't have
all the information they have like
tip offs and they have little snippets
of information that suggests bin laden
is hiding in that that complex in
pakistan but they never know 100
and there's lives at risk he's sending
in 20 or 40 american soldiers to go to
fly into pakistan at night in these
helicopters and if they get caught if
they get shot down then he's gonna have
to you know sit with that for the rest
of his life but he says when you're the
president of the united states and you
have these huge decisions to make you're
never going to get to 100 certainty so
what he did which i really do believe in
is once you get to like 51 certainty on
your decision then make it and be at
peace that you did the best with the
information you had because so many
people and this is kind of what he
didn't say but what i took from it is
what ends up happening is the
procrastination of the decision
um ends up costing you more in the long
term than actually just making the
decision and finding out if you're right
or wrong because like it's the same in
business if i i'm thinking about
something but i'm not entirely sure but
i suspect it's the right thing i should
just go ahead and make the decision
and then find out hopefully in the next
couple of months whether i was right if
i was wrong i can actually just reverse
the decision again
but a lot of people spend like years
remunerating over these like
relationship decisions or work decisions
or professions they cost themselves 10
years which does more damage than the
decision itself at 51 would have done
exactly that so and i honestly
it was like i listened to that at the
best time
then the next day i did it
and i honestly felt
the
the reason that i knew as soon as i'd
done it that i'd that i knew it was
right well i knew anyway but the
reassurance i had is i felt the
emotional side of it i hated i hated
you know
the phone call and the
meeting and the you know letting people
feeling like i've let somebody down and
in the sense of upsetting them because
they would have probably liked to have
continued working together so i felt i
don't want to upset anyone it's not bad
blood it's just making a decision i need
to make for myself
and
i felt
shitty first of all because i felt like
oh god do you think they're really upset
do you think
but that's
that's all i felt
everything else i felt like i had just
had a massage and a weight was off my
shoulders and i was like okay right now
we go isn't it funny how we always know
um we always know
i was ready i felt like i needed to
celebrate the only thing i felt bad
about was potentially upsetting
somebody
but everything else was right everything
else there was like i felt like oh thank
goodness i've done that there's so many
people listening to this podcast now
that know
the answer to a decision and in fact
because of that psychological discomfort
associated with making the phone call
letting someone down they procrastinate
off into the future but they know
you know like i always think with the
major decisions in my life especially
the ones which i really did dither and
procrastinate over and regretted not
making quicker i knew early and i
actually talked myself out of it because
i was trying to avoid that discomfort of
confronting it and that's what it is
it's the
like
when i say confrontation and it's not in
the aggressive sense it's that
actually having to deliver that news
that's the what some when you know
something's right and you know it's
something you want to do and you are 51
plus
percent sure
the hardest thing you have to do is
deliver it so do you know what i said i
was like i've just got to put my big
girl pants on as i call him i'm going to
pull up my big girl pants
and
if that's the worst part of this
then that is just do you know me if that
is the worst part the worst part is that
essentially you're a good person because
you like you said you don't want to
upset so you're skirting around it
because you don't want to actually have
to say it
but you know it's right and that will
nine times out of ten be the worst part
i think is delivering it because you
know it's right for you and your journey
and you just have to lean into that and
just
get the balls too and it's that once
you've done it you'll feel
you will just feel so liberated it's
crazy
we have a tradition on this podcast
which is a fairly new tradition where
the previous guest
asks the next guest a question oh and i
actually i don't know whether people
believe me or not i actually don't know
the question because what happens is
they sign it they pass the book to jack
and then jack places this in front of me
the next time we have a guest okay so
i'm going to read this one for you
what would you like to pay attention to
that you don't currently pay attention
to
and why
oh that's a really good question
do you know what i would like to pay
more attention to
this is and this isn't
i'm not a bad person by the way you
don't need to worry
i would really like to pay more
attention to my dog
okay is this really this is really a
simple answer i know
however
i work a lot in the day marvin works
evening so he's around a lot in the day
so he does all the stuff with the dog
but when i walk through the door she
loves me so much
so unconditionally
i think i've not even seen you all day
and she's around and you know yes we
might we've gone out for the walk and
i'm doing the kids and then i've got
what you know
and then i think oh i've not really like
laid on the sofa and really like
made the most of you it almost feels
undeserved doesn't it to some degree
yeah the excitement i get from my dog
after i've walked through the door after
a month in new york
yeah you'd expect them to be pissed off
in the corner like that oh yeah now
you're rolling this time yeah
what don't you call this yeah so i feel
like i would like to this is really yeah
i'm going to sound like a really bad dog
owner i promise you i'm not she's she
has so much love but i would just like
to give her a bit more attention
rochelle thank you thank you for coming
here today and having this conversation
with me it's been
incredibly uh inspiring it's taught me a
bunch of lessons about the importance of
authenticity as well and being your true
self because i can tell from you know
this um brief encounter that you are
you're you've kind of leaned into your
own authentic self and that's and it's
so evidently clear where that's taking
you in terms of fulfillment and being a
solid human being and your kindness and
your empathy and that's really what i
take from you there's so much
inspiration surrounding how the hell
you're managing to juggle three kids and
build this business and all that stuff
but the overarching feeling is you just
feel like this very bright light i know
you're bad at taking compliments because
i know you said so in an interview or
two but i've not i've just not mastered
that yeah yeah yeah
yeah i just can't thank you i appreciate
it i just can't say thanks i'm just like
oh no i'm not no it's fine
but you are you're an incredibly bright
light and um
that's probably also why you've built
such a phenomenal community because that
comes through like you can't act like a
good person you either are you aren't
and you clearly definitely are so thank
you for giving me your presents today
and thank you for all the wisdom it's
been incredibly um fruitful conversation
for me and i'm sure everyone listening
has enjoyed it thank you i've really
enjoyed it thank you thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you